this program is brought to you by Emory
University
of course vaccine research should
continue as well because we all dream
about an HIV vaccine and since the data
of the Thai trial which has been for the
first time revising at least thirty
percent of protection in some volunteers
we are of course expecting to our data
with other vaccine candidates that are
on the pipeline today but you know I
mean when you make a vaccine trial is
taking a long time to get the data
so but again I think the vaccine
research it's also more promising these
days that it has been in the future
because after the step trial you know
this trial that was very disappointing
it has been a lot of thinking around the
scientific community globally and today
I feel that there is a really much more
integration between basic research and
clinical research on vaccine science and
this is very important for the
development of future vaccine candidate
for HIV
and I am personally convinced that the
progress that we will made in vaccine
research on HIV will serve also for
research and vaccine on other area I
mean for example malaria we don't have
any vaccine to that impressed infection
we don't have any vaccine appt at ITC we
do not have a vaccine yet so we really
need to understand better the mechanism
the correlative protection as we said in
order to develop future vaccine
candidate and to test these vaccine
candidates
you
the preceding program is
Emory University